murieron trabajando para proteger la
selva amazónica y a las personas que
viven en ella el periodista británico
Don Phillips y el experto indígena
brasileño Bruno Pereira fueron
brutalmente asesinados mientras
realizaban un reportaje en el valle
amazónico yabari cerca de las fronteras
con Colombia y Perú tres Pescadores
ilegales han confesado haberlos matado y
según el periódico de Guardian en el que
colaboró Philips el líder de una
organización criminal transnacional ha
sido acusado como presunto autor
intelectual del crimen Mientras tanto el
jefe de asuntos indígenas del gobierno
del ex mandatario Jair bolsonaro fue
acusado de tener un papel indirecto en
los asesinatos el presidente brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva ha culpado a
su predecesor de fomentar los crímenes
medioambientales y ha prometido justicia
en nombre de un Brasil soberano del
planeta y del legado y la memoria de
domi Bruno luchamos para reactivar las
políticas de protección de los pueblos
indígenas y de la selva amazónica pero
esa lucha se enfrenta a la oposición del
poderoso lobby agroindustrial brasileño
y por otro del Congreso de mayoría
conservadora la semana pasada la cámara
aprobó proyectos de ley que limitarían
el poder del nuevo Ministerio de pueblos
indígenas de Lula y dificultarían el
reconocimiento de las tierras indígenas
el pueblo guaraní está aquí marchando y
luchando contra estas leyes de genocidio
y genocidio que se centran en la
destrucción de las personas originarias
de estos territorios
estos proyectos de ley no solo afectarán
a los pueblos indígenas sino a todo el
planeta
los proyectos aún deben ser aprobados
por el senado y promulgados por el
presidente pero aunque Lula se niegue a
firmar el congreso podría anular su